[Música]
boa noite momento todos
é difícil falar depois de tanta gente
com experiências são interessantes e
vivências tão diferentes e díspares mas
que nos tocam da mesma maneira e acho
que o que eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês
aqui hoje de alguma forma também é
tentar de um jeito muito modesto enreda
tudo isso né pensar as experiências
humanas mas eu tenho uma marca tem que
esperar a aparecer um slide atrás de mim
depois após começar a falar
então vamos lá a minha ideia com vocês
hoje é parte de um pressuposto comum
nenhum de vocês deve descuidar de uma
afirmação que eu vou fazer agora nós
vivemos em redes têm redes de contato
têm redes sociais redes de todos os
tipos
a rede parece pautar a maneira pela qual
nós vivemos a minha grande questão é
será que viver em redes é a mesma coisa
que viver conectado e para isso é
preciso entender o que significa a rede
o que significa conexão para entender o
que significa conexão eu trouxe o óbvio
um dicionário e vocês olhando essa
definição vão descobrir que a conexão
tem a ver com união ligação à minha
pergunta óbvia que decorre dessa
primeira afirmação seria entender quando
começou esse processo de conexão quando
nós nos tornamos a uns seres muito
próximos uns dos outros
eu diria que sempre essa é a maior
característica humana que eu posso
destacar a nossa espécie é uma espécie
gregária nós vivemos juntos vivemos uns
com os outros
desde a pré história se existe uma
possibilidade existem várias mas uma
possibilidade nos distinguir como seres
biológicos para seres históricos seres
culturais
é exatamente isso a nossa necessidade de
cultura cultura é preciso que alguém me
ensine as coisas quando alguém nasce
reparo não sabe falar não sabe andar
se for comparar com outros primatas
outros mamíferos
é interessante perceber que esses outros
bichos nascem andando
nós pensamos ser carregados um ano e
meio dois até dar os primeiros passos ea
gente vai trombando pela vida com esses
passos o resto da nossa existência
então a nossa maior característica como
espécie é precisar um do outro é preciso
que alguém ensine a ser humano
então a gente tem que pensar o que nós
estamos fazendo hoje eo que nós vamos
ensinar essa geração que é uma geração
de jovens
então é um fenômeno recente a conexão
não é um fenômeno da espécie e vou dar
alguns exemplos seu olhar pra história
na pré história vai encontrar
instrumentos de pedra e de outros muito
próximos uns dos outros isso vai dizer
que um grupo fazia instrumentos de pedra
com alta qualificação
naquele momento naquele lugar mas se eu
for um sítio arqueológico próximo eu
descobri que mudava muito pouco e
perceber influências que permitem dizer
que essas pessoas trocavam na
pré-história experiências umas com as
outras elas eram conectadas e encontrou
pedras lascadas ou pedras polidas no
planeta inteiro
depois eu tive rota da seda que vai
conectar o oriente ao império romano por
exemplo eu vou ter rotas no pacífico eu
vou encontrar rotas de comércio e troca
entre os índios na américa muito antes
da chegada dos europeus com as
navegações isso começa a se tornar um
lugar comum
reparem com as navegações eu vou
encontrar produtos chineses sendo
vendidos na europa
eu vou encontrar produtos chineses sendo
vendidos na américa esse processo vai se
tornando cada vez mais intenso muito
mais forte com o tempo e quando chega o
século 18 século 19 com as revoluções
industriais acontecendo ea criação de
novas tecnologias telefone mas pra
frente rádio no século 20 televisão e
finalmente a internet e para que eu vou
encurtando o mundo vai ficando menor ea
nossa capacidade de conexão parece
aumentar estava dizendo então luís que
sempre nós somos conectados então nada
mudou
mais ou menos eu falei que nós sempre
fomos conectados mas que só aumentou e
intensidade
e quando a intensidade muda muda também
um tipo de fenômeno que está analisando
vou dar um exemplo e aí eu espero que
seja um exemplo que toca a todos vocês
por que toca a mim no século 16 por
exemplo quando alguém queria saber um
rei por exemplo queria mandar uma ordem
para a américa e essa ordem chegava até
aqui tinha que ser despachada as
autoridades que recebiam dizer sim ao
que recebemos vamos cumprir vamos
cumprir e precisa informar o rei de
volta esse processo poderia demorar um
ano ou mais
quem esperar um ano por uma resposta
hoje em dia a maior parte de nós não
consegue esperar dois minutos
é isso quer dizer como muda aí mudando a
intensidade muda também o fenômeno em si
então não é pouca coisa que estou
dizendo nós sempre somos conectados a
conexão como existe hoje muda
completamente a maneira pela qual as
pessoas se vêem bom pra isso eu queria
analisa esse fenômeno recente
esse fenômeno dos anos 2000 pra cá
talvez dos anos 90 pra cá mas a maior
parte de vocês são jovens e pensar um
pouco a experiência de vocês a partir
dos anos 2000 houve três promessas com o
surgimento dessa lógica de uma aldeia
global espero que prometiam e de uma
noção de que nós somos inteiros
enredados em que essas redes nos
aproximar iam ainda mais a primeira das
promessas era mais contato entre as
pessoas
nós ficaremos mais próximos uns dos
outros eu poderia me responder com
alguém na rússia
alguém da rússia poderia se corresponder
com alguém do chile que se corresponder
com alguém na áfrica ou na austrália aí
vai
para isso pois bem a segunda promessa é
decorrente disso nós nos tornamos muito
mais capazes de sentir empatia porque
trabalhando o tempo todo com pessoas
diferentes de mim eu descobri formas
distintas de vida e descobrir maneiras
diferentes e pentear o cabelo de vestir
uma roupa de sentir algumas coisas de
comer isso enriquecer quem eu sou
aprendendo a respeitar o próximo ea
terceira das promessas era mais
liberdade por exemplo liberdade de
escolha é fácil você entender eu não
quero mostrar tal coisa eu clico no
celular
e alguém de moto vem entregar aquilo que
eu
era o começo se não for após
entendimento de escolha para qualquer
coisa por exemplo né
eram três promessas contato empatia
liberdade havia outras quatro
estou tentando analisar com vocês essas
três e curiosamente essas três promessas
resultaram em 3 paradoxos e eu queria
analisar com vocês
esses paradoxos agora o primeiro se a
promessa era mais contato
curiosamente o que acontece é que nós
estamos cada vez mais sozinhos
a gente fez aquele levantamento antes de
começar a falar sobre quem é que se
sente ansioso ou quem se sentia
deprimido conhecia alguém nessa
circunstância é maior parte de vocês
levantou a mão esse é um dado
estatístico a quando eu era criança nos
anos 80
há no mundo muito mais sólido do que
esse mundo líquido que estou tentando
desenvolver com vocês aqui o que
acontecia era que a gente desenvolver
vários tipos de neurose relacionados à
identidade e ailson cineasta como o
diálogo em fazer todo o sentido
agora a geração atual não desenvolve
esse tipo de neurose e desenvolve
depressão síndrome de burnout e
ansiedade
agora se eu fizesse uma outra pergunta
estão ansiosos com o que ninguém sabe a
gente avance ozu ponto eu sou ansioso
agora vou entrar na questão da solidão
pra ver se eu consigo explicar para
vocês
talvez uma razão tinham uma ponta de um
iceberg pra gente começar a pensar junto
a partir dessas questões o mundo
prometia mais contato mas como funciona
por exemplo uma rede social
eu bato um self uma selva eu nunca sei
veja nós não criamos o auto retrato
muito menos o retrato as pessoas pedem
para pintar a si próprios desde que o
mundo é mundo especialmente na
modernidade e sustentou a vida de vários
pintores que vocês estudaram na escola
alguém pedir para faço o meu retrato
depois da fotografia ou viu o
autorretrato é que era mais difícil é
complicado hoje você bate 30 fotos de
você mesmo em uma única situação fica
olhando para si
em qual você saiu melhor aí você sobe
isso por uma rede social e fica
desesperado esperando ser curtido e fica
muito chateado
se alguém não comentou a foto ou se você
não recebeu uma curtida uma discutida é
terrível com uma pessoa mas repare como
terrivelmente solitário você vai ter uma
foto de você mesmo olhou pra foto o dia
inteiro postou e ficou olhando o que
falar sobre você de novo você está
vivendo sozinho e sem perceber isso pode
criar um paradoxo ainda maior que o
paradoxo do solipsismo a palavra
estranha mas a imagem ajuda um pouquinho
é a idéia de que nós estamos curvado
sobre nós mesmos sobre nosso próprio
umbigo o tempo todo então a promessa era
contato e o que a gente tem
solidão estou em contato com pessoas mas
eu só falo comigo mesmo
em compensação segundo paradoxo por
favor o segundo paradoxo tem a ver com a
segunda promessa que não foi feita
se a ideia era ter mais simpatia
curiosamente o que acontece é que nesse
mundo de isolamento no qual a gente vive
em que eu passo o tempo todo com o
pescoço para baixo fazendo assim
enquanto eu tô falando eu tenho certeza
que tem alguém fazendo assim não me
ofendo fique tranquilo
eu sei que é mais é compulsivo é mais
forte do que nós
eu tenho a cada dois minutos que olhar e
ver o que aconteceu então fica isolado
nessa bolha zinha que eu criei para mim
mesmo achando que estou vivendo com
outras pessoas mas eu vou de novo dar um
exemplo acho que vocês já viram um
almoço em família ou você vai a um
restaurante e um casal de namorados
jantando
como essas pessoas almoçam ou jantam
olhando o celular
elas estão sentados à mesma mesa o tempo
todo assim sim claro vão bater uma foto
da comida e postar pelo que o pessoal
fala é o que já tinha curte né
as pessoas estão ali e não estão ali
elas estão juntas e não estão juntas e
mais isso leva a um outro fenômeno pior
que o antagonismo é o oposto da empatia
empatia uma palavra está na moda
ninguém pratica é só pensar por exemplo
que foram as nossas últimas eleições mas
aqui estou sempre pensar no brasil
pode pensar no mundo inteiro esse é um
fenômeno global de antagonismo as
pessoas por um aplicativo de conversas
mandam mensagens umas para as outras
ofendendo mas as outras normalmente eu
preciso responder o fulano ou fulana que
mandou aquela agora é preciso responder
neste exato momento e vou mostrar a
verdade para esta pessoa pronto criei um
caso de antagonismo aquela pessoa foi um
churrasco na sua casa na semana passada
você conhecia acertam parente que você
gostava um tio
mas naquele momento aquela verdade
daquele grupo é muito mais importante e
você cria uma discussão antagonismo e
mesmo com uma facilidade do mundo em
rede você bloqueia a pessoa que você não
gosta mais
e agora tem mais eu gosto mas você põe
pessoa para dormir por 30 dias
é um efeito dominó 30 dias se você volta
melhor mas no fundo o que a pessoa está
dizendo concorde comigo ou morra suma do
mundo
repare como o paradoxo nos prometeram
empatia e nós temos cada vez mais
isolamento em antagonismo terceiro dos
paradoxos deve acontecer a promessa nos
prometeram liberdade nos deram a ilusão
de que nós somos livres
eu vou dar um exemplo agora da minha
infância eu nunca tomei refrigerante
meus pais eram meio e porongas não deram
para claro que o meu irmão mais novo de
mama litros de coca cola como se fosse a
última coisa do planeta eu nunca tomei
mas eu me lembro que você comprar
refrigerante nos anos 80 e tinha lá 34
marcas 5 no máximo não tinha bike light
0 no isso não existia em 2010 é melhor
ou pior fazendo uma constatação era
assim
se eu fosse comprar um cereal tinha 11
cereal que quem é um pouco mais velho
que sabe do que estou falando pode até
cantar o jingle mentalmente
esse era se você quisesse comercial
chegasse no supermercado não tivesse não
tinha outro para comprá ponto não tem
outro para contar
você vai comprar o cereal ou
refrigerante hoje como é que um milhão
de refrigerantes em todas as versões e
sabores possíveis
o cereal tem com glúten sem glúten com
açúcar
açúcar com açúcar de coco porque agora
está na moda que o índice glicêmico mais
baixo tem com lactose sem lactose tem de
milho tem de arroz tem colorido tem sem
cor
tenho que não tem gosto de nada ontem
granola como é que a gente escolhe as
coisas diante disso entendo que são
ansiosos
você não sabe escolher a gente acha que
ter muitas coisas da gente a sensação de
que nós podemos escolher melhor não
repare
isso é um excesso de positivo tem muito
muito excesso e escolher é um ato
negativo é o negativo faz bem para o ser
humano
o tempo todo a gente tem tap pula e
gente que é legal bacana tudo pra cima
da hora que é legal pra baixo
vou dar um exemplo disso vocês não
conseguem ficar sozinhos não conseguem
ficar sozinhos quando vocês estão
sozinhos estão aqui vendo coisas aí é
uma e meia da manhã
e vocês estão vendo coisas duas da manhã
e tem um compromisso a 6 mas não
consegue dormir tudo vai parar porque o
silêncio não ter nada pra fazer por
exemplo é algo que não condiz com os
nossos dias só que coisa interessante
quando você não tem nada pra fazer
você sente uma coisa que não sei se
vocês se sentir ultimamente chamada
tédio e quando a gente tem pédio a gente
se torna criativo inventar alguma coisa
a fazer é passar o tempo então eu vou
cantar vou aprender um instrumento como
vocês viram aqui eu vou ler fazer alguma
outra coisa que seja criativa
se eu estou o tempo todo com a mente
ocupada com a minha própria vida com as
minhas próprias fotos com os meus grupos
as minhas discussões o que é importante
pra mim eu sou o oposto do livro eu não
escolhi nada eu vivo tudo portanto não
vivo nada tem um filósofo que diz que
nós a frase do século 21 até agora eu
tornar se alguém é para alguém não é
ninguém
alguém uma pessoa que não sei quem é que
não tem um modelo uma referência
a seguir eu quero vir alguém nós vimos
uma outra toque aqui dizendo isso quero
ser rico eu quero ser famoso
repare que o tornasse é um verbo que é
um processo
eu nunca chegou a lugar nenhum eu estou
sempre me tornando algo
isso dá uma angústia tremenda isso causa
dúvidas o tempo todo nas pessoas eu
escolhi corretamente o que eu fui fazer
não sei eu tomo decisões baseado em
dúvidas e vocês tomam decisões a cada
minuto a cada segundo uma atrás da outra
isso causa inequivocamente angústia
o que a gente acha que a liberdade é o
oposto
você é preso a incapacidade de escolha
como é que a gente sai disso com a
solução para essas coisas
bom alguém poderia pensar esse cara ele
é um pessimista e ele vai falar
abandonem as redes
abandone a internet vamos voltar para o
tempo das cavernas que gera mais
conectado lá é verdade era mais
conectado lá mas não dá para abandonar
essas coisas nem precisa não é isso o
que estou dizendo que vamos usar essas
ferramentas e não ser usados por ela a
frase pode parecer simples mas a prática
não é como é que eu sei que não estou
sendo usado por isso quando eu uso de
maneira crítica as coisas quando eu
penso sobre o que eu faço
bom então vamos tentar entender como é
que eu faço isso de maneira crítica
para entender isso é preciso pensar
alguns verbos algumas ações passar o
slide por favor
primeiro um cuidado anterior vício às
vezes as pessoas são viciadas e aí é uma
questão médica estou pensando antes
dessa questão se você por exemplo não
consegue abaixar o celular ou tablet
de maneira nenhuma ao longo de um dia se
a idéia de ficar sem um smartphone
durante um dia te deixa completamente
insano talvez você tenha um problema
mais grave do que eu escrevendo aqui e é
bom procurar uma ajuda psicológica
psiquiátrica de um passo antes na ideia
de que sim eu consigo tomar esse impulso
que ele é um impulso é humano eu sou
mais inteligente do que ele então vamos
dar uma olhadinha por favor
no que nas ações e no verbo que a gente
analisar primeiro lembrar esse mundo
aqui fora é o mundo que vale a pena ser
vivida o único que a gente
vivi efetivamente aqui que eu conheço
pessoas é que o abraço pessoas é que eu
tenho uma experiência como essa que a
gente teve essa tarde o mundo das redes
é o mundo que deve ser um reflexo deste
daqui e não o contrário como ocorre hoje
hoje curiosamente esse mundo daqui é
pautado por aquele nós escolhemos o
achamos que escolhemos as coisas
pautados nesse mundo da rede
por fim eu preciso me lembrar de um
verbo eo verbo pequenininho
o verbo precisar cada vez que o seu
cérebro falar pra você eu preciso bater
uma foto eu preciso postar eu preciso
discutir pense duas vezes
lembre-se do século 16 daquele um ano
inteiro para fazer uma coisa e tire dois
minutos para tomar a decisão e eu
realmente preciso fazer isso seria mais
interessante continuar vivendo esta
experiência em sua plenitude e ao fim ao
cabo eu posso registrar e não durante a
experiência que eu não vivo nem a
experiência nem o registro
pensem esse verbo e lembre se que ele
pode ser a raiz de uma boa tomada de
decisão
por fim eu queria encerrar lembrando das
duas palavras que a gente começou a
palestra conexão ou rede
lembre-se conexão mostrei pra vocês une
interliga aproxima e o próximo de alguém
me torna tolerante à diferença e à
tolerância que estou dizendo uma
tolerância ativa eu preciso que alguém
seja diferente de mim para que o meu
mundo se alargue porque eu tenho um
horizonte maior do que o do meu grupinho
do aplicativo do celular
senão nunca vou crescer como ser humano
e vamos lembrar que a rede pode ser
muito útil mas a rede numa metáfora de
pesca também pode me afogar
também pode nos aprisionar vamos ter
cuidado
obrigado
[Aplausos]